on poursuit donc cette édition spéciale
star 80 avec trois vedettes de ce film
trois stars des années 80 patrick
hernandez bonsoir jean choix est
également et avec bonsoir à tous les
trois merci de venir nous voir pendant
cette avant première à l'ugc tout à
l'heure en terminant le plateau je
posais la question à richard anconina et
jean luc lahaye du plus grands tubes des
années 80 on va continuer sur ce
registre là le plus grands tubes des
années 80 pour vous c'est quoi
interdit forcément que c'était son
propre répertoire vous avez droit
j'avais envie de répondre ben bella je
sais oui je gère j'aime j'aime beaucoup
confidence pour confidence
il en coûtera tout
on a tous mon tube absolument
incontournable
et en plus vous remarquerez que
l'originalité de ses tubes c'est
qu'aucun ne ressemble à un autre
ça c'est quelque chose d'extrêmement
déterminant dans les années 80 et ça
permet justement à chacun de ses tubes
d'exister séparément g contient quand
même sur cette question du plus grand
tube n'êtes pas obligé de me répondre
non plus à l'icm ans et patrick le lay a
baissé partout bruel a évidemment
d'abord parce que c'est un tube
international planétaire ce qui n'est
pas le cas des nôtres nous sommes
franco-français franco belgo français en
fait oui oui oui c'est vrai il ne ferait
toutefois à ça c'était le défi c'était
de le caser pendant le plateau à avoir
compris et pour vous le plus grand tube
alors vous connaissez la définition d'un
tube en belgique et c'est quelque chose
de creux qui a un début et une fin
donc nos chansons sont pas des tubes
puisqu'elle continue
dès 6 ans qui rime avec un jour c'est la
mer
l'ambiance au moment du tournage
justement ça s'est passé comme ça
véritable mère pire encore c'était pire
alors une anecdote un forcément vous
mais le seigneur en fait le tournage est
à l'image de ce qui a été la tournée de
ce que toujours la tour d'aigues vives
que on est une bande de potes une bande
de potaches qui s'amusent ensemble et
qui vont de zani tanzanite voir des gens
qui chantent les chansons plus fort que
nous et même en belgique
les frites une fois nous n'avons rien à
vendre finalement à l'heure actuelle
mais si je passerai la main à la fin on
terminera par sa garde et là pour tout à
l'heure en fait nous avons déjà vendu
nos disques est là nous ne sommes pas
complète comme nous le fur
nous le fûmes où le film va être mieux
dans les années 80 est donc là ça crée
une bonne ambiance forcément et personne
n'a rien à prouver aux autres donc
forcément ça ça fait une grande
collégiale très rigolote c'est un peu
colonies de vacances et on les potaches
dans le monde et potages dans l'âme
copley l'ambiance et et peu d'entre vous
on le voit bien et c'est comme ça
également auront-elles je vous le dis
puisque je vous ai entendu un petit peu
discutée dans les années 80 c'était
pareil où il y avait une compétition
tout de même pour faire vivre vos temps
on n'avait pas de on est pro n'était pas
aussi je veux dire intimement lié
qu'aujourd'hui puisque à l'époque on s'y
met chacun sa trajectoire on se croisait
sur les plateaux on se disait bonjour on
savait le travail que les autres faisait
on l'entend à les chansons des autres on
respecte et infiniment nos petits
camarades mais on n'était pas on n'avait
pas l'occasion d'être tous les jours
ensemble quand on était sur la tournée
et sur le tournage donc évidemment quand
on a été sur la tournée ça a été
immédiatement une à la fois on a on a
rencontré vraiment les autres parce
qu'on n'oserait pas encore côtoyé de
près et puis des liens d'amitié
évidemment sont créés et puis après
c'est devenu une grande une grande bande
de joyeux drilles
voilà c'est un plateau très masculin
l'ambiance s'est passé comment avec les
femmes du tournage parce qu'on les voit
sur la fille derrière on va savoir
humain ou jeanne mas aussi très mal
elles ont crié les unes après les autres
mais il en reste deux en fait avant il y
avait dit cette femme mais voilà il ya
tout et puis j'ai déjà pu débarquer leur
cargaison
ben vous imaginez être avec 15 personnes
comme nous c'est insoutenable qu'un ce
potage c'est dur pour les faits les plus
résistants sont restés donc sabrina et
sloan qui sont deux femmes bien bâti à
sabrina fait du karaté et souhaite
imposante pour que l oms l avoir du
caractère pour s'imposer au milieu de
cette troupe
voilà peut-être quatre gratte moi oui
justement vous le disais aussi tout à
l'heure vous n'avez plus rien à vendre
aujourd'hui la tournée qu'ils aient lieu
qui se poursuivent alors cette caravane
qu'on n'oublie pas on va en parler avec
les notaires ne vous inquiétez pas en
tout cas rien à vendre musicalement pour
l'instant mais ce film aussi star 80
c'est pour être un tremplin pour après
est-ce que ça vous a donné le goût aussi
de remonter sur scène tout seul de
proposer autre chose aussi au public
d'autres titres nous nous sommes invités
déjà les uns les autres à participer à
la tournée 2013 qui va commencer en
février donc tout le monde a accepté
avec grand bonheur des jardins et se
veut non non moi je pense que chacun
voit midi à sa porte on regarde
certaines personnes vraisemblablement
des velléités de sortir d'autres disent
ou de choses qu'on n'a pas ce qui me
concerne c'est non pour le cinéma on
sait pas on verra où le film voilà on va
voir les seins on va voir ce que ça fait
et puis chacun mènera sa vie comme nous
avons l'habitude de le faire comme quand
nous sommes chacun dans notre coin
moi personnellement ça m'a beaucoup
inspiré d'être avec cette bande de fous
dans la tournée et ça m'a donné plein
d'autres idées j'ai pas du tout envie de
chanter de me cantonner à c'est l'amour
j'adore cette chanson mais
voilà donc les gens et je rentre je me
suis rendu compte que sur le tournage
que c'était un vrai métier
d'autant plus que c'est extraordinaire
c'est que quand je les regarde et les
deux là timsit et anconina
on les regardait jouer une scène a été
sur le côté sont les regarder jouer
j'avais l'impression qu'ils faisaient
rien oui c'est bizarre ils font rien moi
je peux faire la même chose ils font
rien et puis on retrouve devant la
caméra et qu'on voit après les scènes
qui ont été tournées on se rend compte
qu'il faut par exemple ou à l'acteur
pour vous ce sera non voilà merci à tous
les trois on va une caravane qui a une
option intéressante c'est qu'en fait il
ya un évier sépare évidemment cette
phase de regarder la caméra pour bien
rendre cette caméra à laisse donc voilà
ça sent le mot de la fin sur cette
séquence cette caravane que j'ai appelé
africa en souvenir de rose laurens est
une caravane présidentielle et vous
pouvez vous prendre cette caravane
complètement plongé dans l'esprit des
années 80 et une friteuse strict très
bonne avec de la graisse de boeuf il en
reste encore un peu et je mes amis sont
témoins que l'afrique est croustillante
dans ma caravane
voilà merci à tous rendez vous sur le
site caravane point be2 comme belgique
fin de cette édition spéciale sur tv fil
78 merci aux acteurs du film star 80 qui
sont venus se prêter au jeu répondre à
nos questions réalisations signées roman
russe finit aux cadres guillaume comme
c'est elodie moines on se quitte avec un
dernier morceau qui a fait beaucoup
chanter le public ici à 50 ans une usine
à l'ugc born to be alive
à bientôt sur tv fier vous pensez que
pour rien obtenir une autogreffe de
sabrina
o 1
là
je suis au
je suis au fond
et y sommes